i think red dwarf is one of the greatest
comedy sci-fi series of all time
welcome to scitrak your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
before we get into this video i just
want to point out the fact that although
normally when i create these videos i
would go back and watch a full season or
at least two seasons of a tv show before
making a review on it i didn't do that
with this particular video because i was
on holiday so everything i say in this
video is going to be very raw very
honest and very anecdotal however
that being said i hope you enjoy what i
have to say
so as i said at the beginning of the
video i think red dwarf is one of the
greatest sci-fi comedy series of all
time
and there's a few reasons why i think
that but first of all if you haven't
heard of red dwarf you've never seen it
let me give you a brief explanation of
what red dwarf is about as mentioned it
is a comedy series primarily but it is
also science fiction it doesn't take
itself too seriously and that's one of
the best things about it but the basic
premise is this there was essentially a
radiation leak on the mining ship red
dwarf which killed the entire crew
except for
one person named dave lister played by
craig charles who was in a stasis
chamber because he'd committed a crime
the crime being that he'd had a cat on
board so while she was in this cryogenic
sleep stasis
thing
the entire crew of red dwarf completely
died
millions and millions of years passed
and he eventually woke up when all the
radiation had dissipated woken up by the
ship's computer holly upon his awakening
he finds that
holly has resurrected one of his former
crewmates rimmer rimmer is now alive but
in a holographic state which means as a
hologram he can't do things that normal
people can he can't touch things taste
things
do anything that a normal person can
because he's literally just made of
light now in the first season there is a
third member of the crew called the cat
and that ties back to dave lister's
original crime
as i mentioned dave lister was put in
two states because he had a cat on board
now when the crew of red dwarf all died
uh essentially the cat survived somehow
had babies who eventually evolved into a
human-like creature with cat features
the cat is played by john danny john
jules and he's absolutely one of my
favorite characters on the show he's one
of these wacky characters who's really
into fashion he's very self-obsessed he
always wants to look good
essentially how a cat is they're very
self-obsessed everything's all about
them and he just plays the part
perfectly it just makes a really funny
character now in later seasons there was
a fourth character added called crichton
which was a mechanoid robot um and he
was actually one of my favorite
characters as well but i want to talk to
you briefly about dave lister dave
lister is the heart and soul of red
dwarf dave lister is one of these people
who is not going to get anywhere in life
he's a layabout he's lazy he's sloppy
he's messy he's just an all-round
terrible person
[Laughter]
not to say that he's a bad person like
he's really nice and he's got a kind
heart he's just not very good at being a
human and one of his most favorite
things to do in the whole wide world is
really wind up rimmer
rimmer is one of these characters who's
very prim very proper follows the rules
and wants
to progress with his life but he's just
so stupid and so
in his own head that nothing ever goes
right for him so he he is essentially
the comedic value in red dwarf
everything that goes wrong usually
happens to rimmer but that's enough
about the characters let's talk about
the overall themes of the show and why i
think it's one of the greatest sci-fi
comedies so being a sci-fi comedy it's
obviously going to take inspiration from
other science fiction television shows
and movies that have come before it it's
had references to alien as 2001 space
odyssey
star wars and many many other shows but
the thing it does really well is it
doesn't take itself seriously the sets
are really wobbly the cgi and the
prosthetics are really really bad and
the humor is absolutely ridiculous it's
borderline slapstick and that's what
makes it genius
red dwarf was very very different to
everything else that had come before it
it was a science fiction show which many
science fiction fans absolutely loved
but it was also comedy which meant
you could have a laugh you could sit
down you could watch it and it was fun
for the whole family i am a massive
science fiction fan i love everything to
do with space space battles aliens it's
time travel all of that kind of stuff
and i love red dwarf however
there are people in my family who don't
like any of that
but still enjoy a red dwarf because of
the comedy and because it doesn't take
itself too seriously you watch it and
you think this is terrible but i love it
now red wolf first started in 1988 and
is actually still going now and that is
somewhat of a problem now i love red
dwarf as i've said before but it's one
of those shows that has really outstayed
its welcome there was a period of time
um where red dwarf had basically ended
and we could go back and we could watch
all of the seasons from season one all
the way up to the last episode and enjoy
it for what it was but then they'd done
a reboot and although it was good and it
was still red dwarf
it had slightly higher production value
and
it kind of looked a little bit different
and the charm of everything being a
little bit
you know
slapped together
terrible cgi and terrible prosthetics
it was there
but it wasn't there to the extent that
it was before and i think a good reason
for that is because there was 10 years
in between where red dwarf had come off
the air and went back on the air it
stopped airing in 1999 and was then
revived back in 2009 with a series
called back to earth and
yes i absolutely loved it i will always
love it because it is red dwarf and red
dwarf is one of my favorite television
sci-fi comedy series of all time as i've
said multiple times throughout this
video but for me the golden era of red
dwarf was that initial first run of 10
or so seasons
between 1988 and 1999 those were the
golden years of red dwarf you had themes
such as time travel they explored free
will they explored the idea of you can
have anything you want inside this video
simulation
what do you want and the idea that your
mind will just revolt against you until
you don't want that you want this this
is what you really want and give you
something that you absolutely hate
one of my favorite episodes actually
that was
they went into a video game and of
course they did all the the the things
that you would normally do if you can go
and get whatever you want they had lots
of hot women they had lots of alcohol
they basically did whatever they want
fast cars etc
and then
well it happened to rimmer
as i said he is the comic comedic value
on this
uh he had everything he wanted and then
his mind went against him and he
eventually ended up becoming married to
someone he didn't like having kids and
his life became a misery now i don't
know what that says about rumor but it
was funny to watch then he also had time
travel episodes where
they essentially have echoes from the
past and that you can see into the
future so they explore things like the
grandfather paradox determinism
and destiny things like that and it was
overall
a fantastic show
if you haven't already watched it i urge
you to watch it i believe it's on bbc
iplayer if you're outside of the
uk you'll probably get a streaming
service called brick box which i don't
know if it's available elsewhere but you
can probably find it somewhere yeah i
want to know what you think have you
seen red dwarf did you like it and what
are your overall thoughts on it
let me know in the comment section down
below and if you are new to the youtube
channel make sure you hit subscribe and
press the bell notification so you don't
miss a single video and whilst you're
down there consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker hit the join button
down below
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you next week
[Music]
you